I asked our research team I said guys
tell me everything Tate said that's
pissed people off okay I want to read
some of this stuff sure and you know
some of it's rubbed some people the
wrong way and some of it's offended
certain people but these are some of the
things that you've said in the past
before you said uh it's been proven that
the smartest people in the world are men
okay correct I think you have that with
bar stool Sports and then they came up
with the Portnoy in the highest IQ and
later on it was Grandma come here for a
second you wanna say hi everyone would
love to see you just wave do you guys
haven't already watched the video make
sure you watch the the base Grandma
reacts to Tate video see so this is what
we're doing we're live and um this is
like the chat so someone just donated
twenty dollars oh nice yeah it's pretty
sweet right am I done you're done I'm
done okay good night I will not
administer CPR until you're uh unless
you're a hot female I will not
administer CPR unless you're a hot
female yeah so so what's actually
interesting is and this is what's really
really important because it becomes a
broader argument than just me and what's
happened to me and I want to make
something clear to the social media
companies also as a whole
a lot of the things I said were in
longer format video on YouTube three
four years ago and the way that social
media is being produced and also
digested has changed significantly in
the last year it's all tick tock it's
all YouTube shorts it's all Instagram
stories Tick Tock in real time has
destroyed the attention span oh my God
billions of people have you ever watched
somebody on Tick Tock if you guys
haven't already you have to delete tick
tock I've deleted Instagram snap
Snapchat first Snapchat's a complete
waste of time if you're still sending
pictures of your [ __ ] face to people
online you need to get a grip in reality
and you are killing time you know what
people do is they they go and they take
a picture and then they send someone a
picture and then they open their picture
of someone's face and then they do this
to hundreds of people every single day
it's the biggest waste of time if you're
doing that you need to delete it I have
fallen I have uh you know Fallen victim
to tick tock as you know like yeah
that's not enough videos you know I get
sucked in to puppy videos but I belong
to
um other I have other subscriptions for
exam simple master class I belong to and
I have an annual subscription so that I
can watch other other classes it's like
all well accomplished famous people some
of it's a little old [ __ ] that I don't
like but some of it is really cool so
that when I'm you know if if I'm really
bored standing in line somewhere I can
at least I can watch that and be
learning and absorbing something instead
of just sitting brainlessly like using
that time to be entertained and learn at
the same time instead of just that's the
thing in your brain with this 10 second
[ __ ] when you're on these platforms
your brain isn't coming up with new
thoughts anymore you're not thinking so
you're just filling your brain with
nonsense just to kill time think about
it like whenever you're in the shower
without your phone or you're laying in
bed at night that's when you get your
best ideas you want to know why because
that's the only time that you're giving
your brain the chance to even think of
new ideas because the rest of the day
you're staring at a screen and you're
not even allowing yourself to think of
anything new so delete those apps step
one you have to delete those or at least
treat it like you're trying to quit
smoking or trying to quit any advice
because it is advice so get rid of
device and or at least you know wean
yourself off of it go for a walk and
leave your phone at home oh try that
that would be crazy I only have insta
Tick Tock snap and Discord I would just
delete three of those you don't need
Snapchat you can download it once a day
to check because sometimes you still
have connections that are strictly on
Snapchat that's so I'll delete I'll like
re-download it once or a week or so or
as Tate says [ __ ] control yourself
control yourself leave it on
set it once a day set a reminder you
don't understand people like like even
my brain was like completely wired I do
understand because I live in the same on
the same Planet as you oh it's happened
to me too and but Tate turns around and
you know how he says you know right even
about you know just everything you do
control your mind control what you put
in your mouth control you know who you
talk to you like [ __ ] nacho cheese
that much right you there they said that
whole thing right you like nacho cheese
more than you want to like be alive to
watch your your children grow up are you
kidding me control yourself so and I'm
speaking as much to myself as I am it's
everybody listening and I hope that
that's helpful is it either if you can't
control yourself ditch it get rid of it
yeah on God no cat no I'm saying it's
boring yeah your attention
I don't know focus on the real world you
can't focus or anything ADHD is being
developed in real time from these apps
right so the idea of me producing a
seven eight minute video like I used to
and people consuming all of it and
understanding the context is gone
they'll take one few seconds like me
saying I wouldn't administer CPR to a to
a man for example and it's act it was
actually satire of course it's a joke I
talk at length about how
far that's the whole point it's a joke
but they take that one part they put on
a tick tock boom boom they add some
editing they remove the tonality they
make it interesting and funny and it
goes viral that's fine but the point we
live we now live in a world where
anything you ever say can be taken out
of context anything you've ever said can
be weaponized against you and I'm not
complaining I don't believe in
complaining I believe in responsibility
and I'm not saying I didn't say them I'm
not saying I didn't mean it I'm saying
that most of the people who are upset by
things I've said have heard a few Clips
out of context and never actually
digested any of my content series also
Tick Tock is the greatest and cheapest
platform right now to advertise products
or service 100 100 use tick tock to your
advantage don't scroll on it all day
right that's all I'm saying be a Creator
not a consumer and there's ways on the
algorithm that you can actually show The
Tick Tock algorithm that you're a
Creator rather than a consumer and
that's one and that's one of the things
[Music]
won't last long